AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
ZANGER, I HARDLY KNEW HER.
WELL AN OLD COUPLE IN
ILLINOIS HAS WELCOMED THEIR
100TH GRANDCHILD.
LOOK AT THESE PROLIFIC BABY
BLASTERS, THERE THEY ARE.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN MARRIED FOR 59
YEARS AND THEY HAVE 12 KIDS, 53
GRANDCHILDREN, 46 GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND A GEAT-
GREAT GRANDSON.
>> Chris: THE ZANGER FAMILY
CANNOT STOP (BLEEP)ING.
IT IS A NOT STOP ZANGBANG OVER
THERE.
THEIR 100TH GRANDSON IS NAMED
JAXTON.
WHICH, THAT'S A NAME YOU SETTLE
ON WHEN YOU'VE RUN OUT OF IDEAS.
IT SOUNDS MADE-UP. HIS NAME'S
...JAXTON, I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S WHAT YOU NAME PEOPLE
WHEN YOU HAVE 100 PEOPLE NAMED.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHEN YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO NAME YOUR
CHILD TO JUST NAME THEM AFTER
THEY WERE CONCEIVED.
BY THIS RULE, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY AS NAMES
AS YOU CAN FOR ZANGER CHILDREN
TO COME.
60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
BEGIN.
>> WRIGLEY FIELD DUMPSTER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> DAVE & BUSTERS, THE TWINS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DAVE ANTHONY.
>> WHY ISN'T MY WORKING.
>> UNCLE LARRY'S WATERBED.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> KATY PERRY CONCERT FOOTAGE
ON PAUSE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
I THINK MARC'S BUZZER IS
GENUINELY WORKING.
>> THERE IS IS.
>> SOMEONE WAS TRYING TO (BLEEP)
WITH ME BACK THERE.
BROOKSTONE VIBRATING CHAIR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> FORD FOCUS FRONT SEAT.
>> Chris: WOW, IN THE FRONT
SEAT?
>> YES.
>> Chris: THAT'S AMAZING.
>> THAT'S HOW I ROLL.